with hey Mel Abraham and LeBron right oh
yeah you know I'm chasing Mount Rushmore
all this other stuff because that's the
question that's the question Patrick
yeah I just gotta ask you but go ahead
okay what can he do anything can eat at
this point of his career okay
I mean he's 1/3 it one guy can he do
anything anything for someone like you
who knows this game very very well
you're not gonna take favorites you're
gonna say what you gonna say Ken LeBron
do anything to be known as the greatest
of all time ahead of MJ at this point of
his Corino one won't we know with his
resume everything and he's kind of like
the numbers are not gonna go any higher
what can he do anything well he would
probably have to win seven or eight too
because right now we have to remember
some about Michael he never lost in the
NBA Finals never write never write never
it was all seven so any average sight in
those finals he was averaging like 35
points a game unbelievable he was
putting in work so that's hard but you
said something magic so if LeBron went
seven I'm not a LeBron offender there's
a guy sitting right there was a die-hard
LeBron I just look there's a lot of
LeBron guys here I'm not I'm not hating
on but if he went seven if you win seven
then we got a conversation we got a
conversation we got we got a kind of
thing but but if yeah if we play draft
pick greatest of all time okay
and LeBron wins seven let's just say
let's just say you win some today is
2023 LeBron's got seven okay you have
first pick I have second pick who's your
number-one draft pick Michael mom take
really I'm taking Michael all I believe
we'll take it Michael